france24 en español pasa 24 horas de
difusión diaria 24 horas para informarse
de toda la actualidad de américa latina
y el mundo todos los días desde el
terreno a través de nuestros noticieros
y programas hablamos con los dirigentes
del continente y también de los que
hacen la actualidad política y económica
artística y cultural para ofrecerles una
información incompleta del mundo que
confronta a todos los puntos de vista
nuestras redacciones en américa latina y
en francia trabajan en estrecha
colaboración para estar siempre presente
en todos los eventos importantes y
proponerles una mirada diferente
france24 en español ahora
liberté égalité actualidad